and welcome back everybody on the other
side of the globe social media star
Andrew Tate remains in Romanian prison
on human trafficking and rape charges
but he's expected to find out this month
if he's going to be released anytime
soon now Mr Tate and his brother Tristan
and two others were arrested in December
after Romanian officials uncovered an
alleged human trafficking ring Romanian
law enforcement officials have
identified six victims subjected to
quote acts of physical violence and
mental coercion the victims are also
believed to have been sexually exploited
by members of the group all four
suspects are expected in court this week
for an appellate hearing after a judge
extended their arrest warrants from 24
hours to 30 days each country has their
own set of rules and can get kind of
confusing so we spoke with the Romanian
lawyer to see how this entire process
could play out
now I would say that the next logical
thing that we should look forward to in
this case is the appeal that is going to
be ruled over and if it's going to be
declined as is my prediction right as I
predict then on January 29th the 30 days
period will will be expiring and the
prosecutor has to come again in front of
the judge and he's going to propose one
of these the following three measures
it's either going to propose to extend
our risk for another 30 days
or keep them second one is to keep them
under arrest at home arrest for 30 days
or the third one is to give them is to
set them free but they would have to
come to the police every week to sign
some papers that they are still in
Romania and they are not going to be
allowed to leave the the country now
again my prediction is that they are
going to be set free if they are going
to move to the truck they are going to
be convicted at least in my opinion and
in terms of the prison time if they are
found guilty for all the three
infractions they can face up to 10 to 20
years in in prison the judge will rule
over the decision so there's no jury
involved it's a simple system okay so
the lawyer defends the suspects the
prosecutor attacks if you want the
suspects or charges them right and then
the the judge rules over the matter
aren't a bit different than our system
here Brian I understand you've been
looking into this and I know that
investigators they've been doing a lot
of evidence collection behind the scenes
can you give us some insight into what
that's all about Jesse it's a lot of
evidence but let's dig a little deeper
into what I think is going to be the
strongest evidence and that's going to
come from the women accused of being
trafficked their accounts of being
indoctrinated and trafficked by Tate is
going to be the most damning and it
sounds like the way he uh recruited them
is going to be part of his downfall the
phrase lover boy and no ladies I'm not
talking about Jesse but lover boy method
is a common phrase in Eastern Europe to
describe how abusers course women into
prostitution typically a lover boy
seduces a young vulnerable girl or even
boy into a romantic relationship with
kind gestures promises and gifts they
are too good to be true with promises of
money marriage and a better life once
hooked the black male and threats begin
many victims end up having Stockholm
syndrome and defend their abusers
believing they're truly in love but the
relationship turns to manipulation and
the victims form into the different
forms of prostitution if a woman
testified to this indoctrination this
could be the end for Tate and make mean
present time
compare me to a lover boy I don't know
if I should be flattered or insulted but
Terry we know that Andrew huge following
on social media think that some of his
posts could actually have led
authorities to investigate him in the
first place oh there's no doubt about it
he is really a huge social media person
and he has about 5.7 million people who
are following him and he has over 100
accounts so he posts a lot and a lot of
his posts are demeaning to women so for
instance he doesn't think women should
be able to drive he has said that women
are like children and dogs they have to
be trained and they need to obey and you
know these types of comments will lead
authorities he said women should be
making money for him this is how he
thinks of women so I definitely think
that the way he speaks the fact that he
has all these people who idolize him and
that led authorities to exactly track
him down well I can tell you that if it
doesn't hurt him it's definitely not
going to help him the things that he was
saying on social media